hey good evening you guys
yeah tonight it's my great pleasure to
help the academy honor a truly Fearless
filmmaker
Peter Weir
I'd love and respect you so much Peter I
can remember the first bit of direction
that you gave me
you looked at me and you said Jeff
we're going on a wild adventure now
and I need you man I need everything you
got you're going to be my co-pilot on
this we're going to fly This Plane
together
I thought what a what a wonderful
invitation
and then I thought gee uh
our movie's about a plane crash
I'm not I'm not going to be helping you
to drive this thing into the ground man
but I'm glad it didn't work out that way
but had a wonderful experience a
terrific movie
most most people uh
enjoyed it though I did run into some
folks
who saw it on an airplane
can you imagine yeah
nightmare but uh I gotta think our
mutual dear wonderful friend Robin
Williams for bringing us together
yeah
Robin and Peter had worked on a Dead
Poets Society both were Academy Awards
not me used for that
and uh shortly after that I worked with
Robin on the fisher king
yeah and all he could talk about was
what a wonderful experience it was
working with Peter
and Robin you were right man I mean
everything you said about him was so
true and then some
you know one of the things I think I'm
most actors here will agree with me but
we looked towards the director to set
the tone you know of the set where we're
all going to be creating
and uh this this wild invitation you
know to be his co-pilot that was such a
vote of confidence
and it was a great example of the tone
that just
permeated our set you know one of
collaboration interdependence
and and truth that's another thing
that Peter was always shooting for the
truth in the movie you know what would
the what were these characters really
going through
and
to help us really feel that he invited a
couple who had uh survived the United
Airlines flight 232 that crashed in
Sioux City Iowa in that corn field
and wow what a remarkable meeting that
was
a woman was there just like Isabella
Rossellini's character was there
having her husband up there in the plane
and uh
the fella said and he was talking like
it was just happening yesterday it
happened maybe 10 years ago but he was
so emotionally engaged and he said uh
you know we were up there for 45 minutes
knowing that we were going to crash it
wasn't like oh we're crashing boom it's
up there for 45 minutes and he said it
was so surprising
you would think there was going to be
panic and hysteria but no that wasn't
the case it was very calm
quiet
and he said the airplane cabin was
filled with love it was like a love bomb
went off and everybody was
so still he looked across the aisle and
saw a little woman there who was
frightened and he thought now it's as if
she's my mom remember and he said no
it's not as if she's my mom that's my
mother and he grabbed her hand and
helped her through the experience of the
crash and after the plane crashed
that Spirit continued
they moved out of that plane like there
were just one being
all looking out after each other
and that feeling
that was the feeling that Peter said
yeah that's what it's all about this
feeling of love and and moving together
this interdependence
and I can remember
Peter you're speaking of tone
setting a tone for us
Peters loves music
and every day he would bring a Boombox
with a little you know cassette player
you know taper in there and he had made
a playlist of all the music he thought
might Inspire not only the cast but the
crew every day
scoring our work yeah it was quite
amazing putting this all in the same
emotional page
and even in dailies I love that Peter
when you would we'd be watching dailies
and he'd push his little Boombox and
score the scene couldn't just
unbelievable
at the end of the film he gave us all
our own copy of that tape so we could
remember that that wonderful music
uh
but
since truth is such a
a feature in all of Peter's films I got
to tell you the truth
when you're
in that kind of relationship a deep
creative relationship
you're bound to hit a bumper too you
know
and uh I I made a bomb Peter I don't
know if you remember this you probably
do too
but oh it chills me to even think about
it but it was during the crash scene
and it was towards the end of the movie
we had
maybe two or three weeks ago and we were
all wiped out you know we were working
splits or nights I can't remember
but it was late in the late or early in
the morning you know we've been working
you know 12 16 hours somewhere in there
and Peter had chose to shoot all of the
Masters
first and the other close-ups I think he
wanted me kind of wiped out that's what
I'm thinking I don't know
but he gets to my shot
and it's down low and the seat's
shooting up and I am a wife you know as
an actor you
you get in the shoes of the character
and I was playing that crash for 12
hours you know I pumping all this
adrenaline to my body I was wiped out
and the camera is shooting up there all
right action you know you're about to
hit the ground take one you know ah you
know all right cut
then Peter looks at me and he says
next take don't uh
open your mouth
and there was a switch flipped in my
head man
and I went oh well I can go
it was really sure
and after a long pause Peter goes
yeah do it like that
and you know this totally implacable
expression in his face and I said oh man
I've I've really blown this beautiful
atmosphere that our director has created
what did I do and we left that morning
you know that that day after work and it
was you know kind of feeling sad the
next day before work I had dinner with
my dad who I was seeing quite a bit that
at that time and was telling them what a
wonderful time I was having with Peter
and I told him about what happened and
he he said well you're a lucky guy I say
why he says well you've got a director
who's running his set
with this feeling of love you know and
that my dad always operated uh
with that that feeling as well and he
said you you know what to do I said yeah
yeah yeah
so we show up the day at work early in
the morning I'm in my trailer right here
and it's Peter there he says what the
[ __ ] was that and I said I said come on
Aunt Peter and I I start sobbing and I
started hugging in my because I felt you
know I hear I am Peter's co-pilot
letting my captain down man I felt so
terrible
but uh
I decided you know I'd go over and
apologize to the cast and the crew for
disrespecting our director and and them
too because they've all been working
just as hard as I had but I said I'm
back my sanity is returned I want to
finish this movie with that same energy
that our beautiful director had us all
going on here
and because of that because we had
established that kind of love
interdependent intimate relationship
friendship
that bumps like that
can be wonderful gifts you know they can
be uh opportunities to rise above that
and uh that's kind of what happened that
that week Peter I think and we gave us
the next jolt of creativity to kick on
the next three weeks and it was just a
wonderful experience and I love you so
much man and I I admire yourself
let's take a look at some of Peter's
truthful powerful movies